puis après ça a été la guerre le front
les campe prisonniers vous êtes restés
combien un an et demi prisonnier de
tentatives d'évasion la troisième
réussie après vous allez vous reposer
dans le sud de la France je crois que ça
Saint-Tropez
la première le hasard a voulu que
l'évasion qui aboutissait au passage de
ce qu'on appelle la zone occupée
nous sommes encore en décembre 41
de la zone dite libre
se fait dans le Jura
de ma vie mais où je connaissais une
famille la relation familiale
je me suis arrêté là c'était comme une
sorte de
comment dirais-je de mondiaux je ne sais
comment j'arrive d'Allemagne et j'ai été
reçu délicieusement je suis resté le
temps bien me retaper en buvant du les
frais
discutant avec la mère et les deux
filles qui se trouvaient là qui sont
naturellement restés des administrateurs
et
aussitôt après je suis parti pour
Saint-Tropez
aujourd'hui c'était un délicieux petit
village pour les pêcheurs et pour les
peintres
et pourquoi est-ce que j'ai là c'est
parce que des amis de mes parents qui
étaient une famille juive les vies les
vies d'espace double non
ont accueilli m'ont dit venez chez nous
si bien que je suis passé les premières
semaines
de liberté un peu enivrée dans cette
famille là et voilà vous posez la
question à mon retour à ce que j'ai fait
42 début 42 ça nous amène les 42 vous
êtes donc dans une famille de juifs et
apparemment dans ce petit village à
l'époque le Saint-Tropez
par la suite et même leur fils enfin le
frère de
qui était qui était là
c'est engagé dans la RF et intitulé
C'est une famille qui a été détruite
vous allez après à Vichy oui et pourquoi
alors quel gouvernement de capitulation
qui a eu les lois anti juive vous allez
à Vichy pourquoi vous n'allez pas
Londres la question
et ne pardonne rien c'était une
législation contre les Juifs étrangers
dont j'ignorais tout car dans tout ce
que je vois dans tous les commentaires
qui sont faits on oublie toujours que
pendant toute cette période là j'étais
prisonnier en Allemagne et que met-on
évaluer deux fois en vain j'avais fait
pas mal de stages en prison pas
simplement prisonnier de guerre mais en
prison tout court
c'était à sanglier de connaître ces
choses là et quand je me suis trouvé sur
les Levi de spa au début de 1942 et
maintenant on peut parler mais alors
quand avez-vous appris l'existence de ce
statut l'existence des grandes
concentrations
j'étais comme tous les Français informés
sur je ne sais pas grand chose
en 42
après tout cela vous pourrez lire ça
dans des textes de très grands
résistants et aujourd'hui même dans la
bouche de quelques très important
résistant gaulliste
dirigeants du RPR
c'est la quelques citations mais vous
voyez j'ai rien apporter
facilement donc elle disait j'ai appris
ça en 44
ce degré de sauvagerie
cette barbarie qui était inimaginable
alors on continue mais oui on continue à
Vichy vous entrez
qui nous attend tout à l'heure mais vous
entrez dans un service de documentation
elle raconte vous faites des fiches vous
les rédigez vous-même je ne sais pas
donc c'était des fiches sur on dit les
communistes les francs-maçons les
gaullistes c'est ça
un sujet de plaisanterie ça si c'était
un sujet sérieux je comprends bien
responsable de ce service était un
personnage ou en couleur qui a commencé
par me dire surtout si vous venez chez
moi faut faire tout le contraire et son
nom
Fabre de tyrince qui est un peu plus
tard s'y retiré dans son pays près de
Nîmes où il est devenu un peintre très
estimé et en résistant
très respecté mais à ce moment-là donc
voilà à ce moment-là
la résistance à cette époque il faut
avoir de la chance pour rencontrer des
résidents et on a quand même et je
rencontre précisément là Susie Borel qui
tiendra madame Georges Bideau Bernard de
Salleron qui était un diplomate de
talent et très courageux
Léon Rollin l'ancien patron de l'agence
avas l'un de ses collaborateurs
de ce genre qui est dans la haute
administration de Vichy et qui était des
résistants dans l'âme et qui préparait
la suite c'est à dire qu'il y avait des
résistants ou des résistants potentiels
à Vichy en réels
moins puisque on entend ce qu'on lit etc
donc faut y répondre c'était aussi un
archite que ça c'était pétrodière et
naturellement à peine Pétain a-t-il été
désigné ou si tu en paru du pouvoir en
liqué dans la République au passage
c'était un vieillard qui avait déjà 84
ans
et se sont engouffrés par toutes les
brèves possibles et tous les gens destin
de droite qui avaient des comptes à
régler avec la République ou qui
voulaient te souvenir leur passion comme
antisémitisme ce qui a été le cas de
Xavier Valade quelques autres qui ont
pris un pouvoir inconsidéré et à côté de
ça il y avait beaucoup de ces hauts
fonctionnaires je vous ai cité quelques
uns de ces noms là qui était déjà
impeccables prévus patriotiques
c'est un choix politique vous allez
faire d'entrer dans la résistance c'est
une sorte de révolte patriotique
ça correspondait à mes sentiments
politiques d'opportunités
par une sorte de pente naturelle j'étais
évadé donc de guerre j'ai fréquentais
surtout mes anciens camarades de guerre
et qui s'était évalué comme moi par les
affinités naturelles qu'on recherche à
cet âge on parlait donc surtout de ça on
a commencé à organiser des évasions de
nos camarades qui étaient restés dans
les camps leur envoyer les faux papiers
on leur envoyer des itinéraires pour les
bonnes routes ou des indications sur les
chemins de fer allemand ou la frontières
donc
tu peux à peu à peu alors ensuite il
faut fabriquer des faux papiers alors on
entre en contact avec les gens qui
savent faire c'est justement des
résistants dans d'autres organisations
ça se trouve comme ça quoi c'est pas de
Gaulle ou les résistants qui sont à
Londres qui vous ont influencé
pas c'est une résistance qui se faisait
comme ça entre en France c'était comme
ça vous savez
pas qui a eu des centaines de milliers
de gens qui faisaient cela qui
résistaient vous avez dit à Gilbert que
vous n'aviez jamais flirté avec
l'extrême droite mais avec la droite oui
ils étaient dedans c'était le milieu
mais c'était vous êtes déjà dit tout à
l'heure que j'étais un produit comme
beaucoup de Français de mon milieu de ma
société de mon éducation
j'ai des petites bourgeoisie dans une
petite ville de province quelle
appréciation vous portez
parce que c'était des gens estimables et
bienveillant mais enfin politiquement
leur analyse était loin de celle que
depuis de longues années moi j'ai et ce
combat pour une idéologie qui n'est pas
même à ce moment-là
mais ça c'est le résultat de ma
réflexion personnelle c'est pas si
facile vous savez beaucoup de gens ont
fait le chemin inverse plus commodément
c'est à dire de la gauche à la droite
quel sentiment vous avez vous portez au
maréchal Pétain si vous en souvenez
vachement là on a beaucoup vécu sur
l'idée
idiote mais très répandu que peut être
dans les camps il y avait les cercles
pétains
j'étais contre et j'ai mené une action
pour refuser ce type d'adhésion qui est
au fond devait elle-même idéologique
c'est-à-dire [ __ ] bon c'était une
couverture Révolution nationale ça non
donc c'est pour vous dire que les choses
sont plus compliquées qu'on ne croit
nous on pensait on disait un sujet
général et ce maréchal qui était très
amis
l'un et le parrain est un du fils du
général de Gaulle leur relation
son travail là
de Gaulle de ne pas l'impression qu'il y
avait une collusion ou une complicité
de la radio
ça se passait pas comme ça mais j'ai
vécu sur cette
hypothèse bête pendant un certain temps
et est-ce que vous pensez que vous avez
fait le bon choix vous l'avez fait vous
êtes entré dans la Résistance vous dites
presque c'était la pente par glissement
est-ce que
vous l'avez si j'ose vous l'avez pas
fait tardivement comme d'autres qui sont
devenus après des patriotes ou des héros
écoutez rentrez en France 5 à 41 rentrez
dans la vie et civique
un premier trimestre en gros je résume
en gros parce qu'il y a pas très bien de
tout ça car ça fait quand même 50 3 ans
c'était pour moi quelque chose est tout
à fait naturel et j'ai commencé à me
trouver mêlé à des organisations
dès le mois de juin 42 c'est un moment
une rencontre
les gens intéressants d'ailleurs et qui
sont restés pour la plupart des grands
camarades malheureusement à l'heure nous
parlons beaucoup ont disparu c'est
ce qui va devenir avec d'autres la
Résistance intérieure
notamment c'est d'ailleurs là qu'il y a
eu les premiers makis car les maquilles
ont été constitués surtout par les
garçons qu'on envoyait qu'on voulait
envoyer en Allemagne pour ce qu'on
appelle la relève c'est à dire pour
remplacer les prisonniers d'hier c'était
un odieux marché entre lequel nous avons
pris position et
à partir de 43 là c'était déjà en 42
parce que le leader de cette
organisation qui s'appelait Antoine
Mauduit qui est mort des portations dans
le garde un souvenir très chaleureux
lui faisait ça avec des prisonniers
évadés qui étaient les premiers hors de
la loi
et voilà comment les choses se sont
faites est-ce que c'est à cause de votre
origine familiale votre petit milieu et
en même temps ce que vous avez vécu à ce
moment-là est-ce que c'est à cause de ça
que il y a une sorte d'opposition à deux
Gaules que vous avez rencontré plusieurs
fois par la suite et quelle date de la
collation à l'opposition qu'on a vu
ensuite sur le plan politique et
historique remonte à ce moment-là je
sais pas si clair que ça le premier
ordre que j'ai eu avec de Gaulle c'est
aussi la première fois que je vais
rencontrer c'était dire au début
décembre 1943 à Alger puis il a des
oliviers et là de Gaulle pour donner des
directives aux organisations de
résistance celles que je contrôlais et
celle qui était de mon milieu avait
adopté une attitude je répète du
commandement qui me paraissait mal
adapté à la situation
alors j'ai une idée semble pas que vos
plans soient bons et votre choix des
hommes vrais regrettable 27 ans
en
1943 27 ans donc j'avais pas encore
mais donc ça remonte un peu à cette
période
là je me suis accroché avec lui mais je
dois dire que il a réagi d'une façon
assez noble puisque quelques semaines
après alors que moi j'étais rentré en
France il fallait voir clandestine je
suis rentré le 26 février début mars
Alexandre et parodie qui était un homme
tout à fait remarquable qui était
général du général qui était chargé
d'organiser les pouvoirs civils en cas
de victoire
m'a fait dire que le général de Gaulle
fait que lui-même m'avait choisi pour
étant des cas hommes qui
seraient chargé de tenir l'égalité tout
le temps que le gouvernement c'est à
dire Comité National de Libération
d'Alger et que le général de Gaulle le
même serait empêché le cas échéant de
revenir à Paris et quand au moment de 19
août au matin j'étais à ceux qui sont
emparés des bâtiments publics voilà et
quand maintenant vous célébrer tel ou
tel anniversaire de la libération
que vous parlez pas trop du général de
Gaulle est-ce que vous pensez à cette
époque ça dépend
je ne parle pas du général de Gaulle
quand il n'y a pas lieu d'en parler j'en
parle lorsqu'il est juste d'en parler
bon alors cela ne pas parler au moment
du débarquement
de Normandie parce que les troupes
françaises en tant que tel n'y étaient
pas engagé pas le premier jour en tout
cas et pour dire raison que je comprends
mais enfin quelle est la réalité et en
revanche lorsqu'on parle de la France de
libération de la France et des combats
menés par les gens de la France libre je
parle toujours du général de Gaulle car
je suis pas quelqu'un d'injuste grâce
aux historiens américains comme Paxton
depuis quelques années les livres
passionnants qu'on avait interrogé
récemment à la télé et tant d'historien
français il y a plus de censure
pratiquement autour de cette de cette
période notre histoire vous avez été
témoin vous avez été acteur il y a pas
de censure en tout cas et puis depuis
les quatre sensations que je suis là
mais le mouvement
je préfère comme vous et sourire mais
les vrais résistants eux savent très
bien à quoi s'en tenir c'est à dire
ils se reconnaîtront dans ce que je
viens de déclarer au bout du compte quel
est votre propre jugement sur le régime
de Vichy est-ce qu'il y a des choses qui
sont aujourd'hui pour vous condamnables
et je veux dire irréparable mais écoutez
ça fait combien de fois que je le dis
le première chose qu'on a la table pour
Vichy c'est d'avoir tirer un trait sur
la République
qui était un acte vraiment intolérable
et c'est comme ça que c'est installé en
état de fait non pas le premier jour au
10 juillet mais le 11 juillet
1940 ça c'était déjà condamnable au
début alors je disais c'était la
pétaudière c'est-à-dire un vieil homme
derrière lequel s'infiltrait un tas de
gens qui eux avaient depuis longtemps
une idéologie
je dirais pas que peut-être
un penseur et les gens qui se sont
infiltrés là des gens
bien d'autres gens très connus qui ont
eu un sort contrasté par la suite
on en profitait pour faire une
révolution ils ont voulu appeler la
Révolution nationale et bien ça c'était
des instables parce que ça reposait sur
un certain nombre de données qui est
contraire à tous ceux qui me paraît être
le message de la République et puis il y
avait les
crimes il y a eu des persécutions il y a
eu des persécutions il y a eu des crimes
les crimes se sont surtout ce qui est
criminel c'est la première législation
antisémite et ce qui est les crimes ce
sont surtout répandus lorsque le combat
est devenu plus difficile c'est d'une
part des maquis par la mélisse
et quand vous dit tout à l'heure il y
avait ce personnage qui était âgé puis
avait les autres et en profiter c'est à
dire vous le mettez de côté vous le
mettez dans le même sac non je dis
simplement que c'était sous son autorité
il a laissé faire il a peut-être
encouragé de ce fait sa responsabilité
se trouve engagée vous le pensiez quand
vous avez assisté si je j'ai bien lu
pendant trois jours au procès de Pétain
vous pensez qu'il y avait sa
responsabilité bien sûr la
responsabilité
c'était
je pensais oui que Vichy avait nu aux
intérêts de la France c'était évident
mais vous dites il y a des choses
condamnables vous le dites à titre
personnel au titre de président de la
République
dans la République c'est pas moi
d'écrire l'histoire de la France mais
aux deux titres personnels et public
c'est essentiellement qu'on enable
qu'est-ce que vous disent d'autre mais
pourquoi la République le condamne pas
plus nettement
qu'est-ce que vous croyez qu'on fait les
résistants de l'immédiate après
tout ça cette espèce de on en veut
occulter ce qui s'est passé au lendemain
de la guerre savez-vous qu'il y a eu 127
puni dans leur vie
représenter aujourd'hui comme ça on
vient de découvrir plus de 50 ans après
que Vichy et qu'on a sanctionné c'est
pas vrai et on pourrait se demander
alors qu'on fait les autres qu'est-ce
qu'ils ont fait mais alors encore une
fois
le Pompidou mais on n'avait pas toutes
les indications historiographiques sur
la période tout surtout mais sur
l'essentiel oui encore une fois pourquoi
la République pourquoi la France ne
demanderait-elle pas pardon des crimes
et des horreurs qui ont été commises à
cette époque là non parfois son nom non
la République n'a rien à voir ça
et j'estime moi dans les conscience que
la France non plus dans les pas
responsable que ce sont des minorités
activistes qui ont saisi l'occasion de
la défaite pour s'emparer du pouvoir et
qui ont qui sont comptables de ces
crimes là pas la République et pas la
France
est-ce que vous encouragez tous les
histoires
au nom de la France
[Musique]